hello everyone this is amir from audio
science review
this is another episode in my series to
look at
uh high resolution download music and uh
examine the spectrum and the contents of
them and see if we're getting our
money's worth as we purchase these uh
higher priced downloads
in this case i'm going to cover jazz at
the pawn shop the famous recording
is produced by the label
nuxos or however they pronounce that and
it's according to them it's a dsd
capture
of the tape i assume and
it's offered in multiple formats as you
see uh
i the one that i have i think is at 256
uh fs and uh
stereo i guess they have the
multi-channel versions also um
when i look at my library i only have
one track so i assume this was a demo
that they had
provided for free in the past i don't
have the full album the full album as
you can see it's quite pricey as
at 31 euros so imagine if we convert
that to us dollars a pretty high price
forget what the exchange rate is right
now anyway
i brought this into adobe audition
as is my usual practice
unfortunately audition is not able to
play this track so we're going to have
to only look at the
static display here
and as usual looking at the time domain
display
we see that there is some amount of
headroom there i'm not sure i'm a fan of
so much clustering that's going on here
but
uh at least there's some headroom there
and they didn't try to maximize the
peaks
uh to zero what's interesting and fairly
typical of dst recordings is this graph
so we see the typical exponential
drop-off of music
which is natural and but then what we
see this is
massive hump and increase in uh what is
essentially noise
this is uh characteristics of any dst
recording
excuse me um one bit format is is used
often and
you can't represent music as one bit
obviously
when you encoding that format you
generate tons of tons of
distortion and or noise and to get
around that being
horrendous at inaudible range that noise
is extracted out of the audible range
and push into the ultrasonic area
um noise doesn't go away of course it's
all present here and if you played this
on a system that had
uh this kind of 180 kilohertz bandwidth
it would actually attempt to play
nothing but garbage from here on
if we look at the the scale of how much
useful music we have
you know this is only up to 24 25
killers of useful music
then 80 of this essentially is is pure
garbage that's handed to us to play
and we can see that very clearly here in
the heat map
uh spectrogram where
up to about 20 some kilohertz
we have what looks like natural random
fluctuations in music
but then we have this sea of black
meaning there's nothing useful there and
then
it jumps into intense random noise
clearly nothing from here up to here is
anything useful
there's an old analog tape recording it
wouldn't have any frequency response
you know above here anyway and
so essentially what we have it tons of
tons of garbage
my system that main system my dac can't
play this
high sample rate dsd or any dst until i
upgrade the dac
so i played this in roon and i asked it
to
down sample this to p at pcm at 88
kilohertz which is a nice multiple of
this
sound quality subjectively is okay as
typical of old recordings tape recording
sounds just like a
tape would uh nothing like high
resolution
digital certainly and uh
so i say this is yet again wasted effort
of digitizing content
well beyond what we need and in this
case poor format i wouldn't want to play
these things at
minus 55 db is quite loud compared to
this to the music
except for low base this rivals the
level of
of uh the music itself
is very very exaggerated fortunately
most systems are probably not going to
play this although some amplifiers are
you know wide bandwidth and go all the
way up to a mega years or so
so they would try to pump this into your
speaker and what the speaker will do
with this noise
is unknown may not play it or it may
cook the twitter or the tweeter may
intermodulate and generate distortion in
the uh
audible band who knows uh but you know
this is not music
if we want music we'd want to chop this
off from here on
and when i played it at 88 kilo sampling
i would have 44 kilohertz of
bandwidth which is pretty proper so you
need what i heard is more appropriate
so in some sense if you have this track
you may want to instruct your
audio program to actually down sample it
and and play it at this rate so as to
not pump all this into your
speaker and system uh on this so
another disappointment but again for a
free track that i got
i can't complain too much this good
music
but uh i can't really recommend going
spending 31 euros and downloading this
track
okay that's it and talk to you later in
the future
review this is amir from audio science